Brian Kilmeade, a Fox News host on Fox and
Friends, says Democrats shouldn't pursue impeachment
against Donald Trump.
Which is happening, by the way, because it
might trigger Republicans to do more violence.
This is saying let's negotiate with terrorists.
That's what Brian Kilmeade is saying here.
Let's take a look at the video and then we
will discuss believe that America could be
more effective and has been ineffective because
we've been at each other's throats.
Who could be more disenchanting?
They don't want to be right again.
I want him to run again.
They don't want him to run again.
That's fine.
But you don't understand, too.
There's a lot of people that want him to no
one continued to be a force in the Republican
Party.
Believe a lot what he believes.
He has seventy five million supporters.
So if you have an overarching sense that I
got to bring the country together because
we see what's happening around this country
of 50 state houses are being threatened on
Inauguration Day, this is the last thing you
want to do.
It astounds me right now.
Chuck Schumer, guys, is exploring a possible
workaround using the authority granted to
two senators back in 2004 to reconvene the
Senate in times of emergency.
I assume this and have a quick impeachment
vote.
Fantastic idea.
Mitch McConnell has to sign off on it.
But it would be as dumb as Nancy Pelosi appeared
on 60 Minutes last night and saying the president's
in imminent threat that's been set up so suddenly.
The issue is, oh, there has been so much political
infighting.
That is just hilarious.
But truly, Brian Kilmeade is saying negotiate
with terrorists.
The right thing to do is impeach.
But wait, the terrorists will get violent
if you do it.
So don't impeach only for that reason.
That's that's not his phraseology, but that's
essentially what he's saying.
It's the equivalent of negotiating with terrorists.
These are the people, Kilmeade and his cronies
on Fox who are always saying you don't negotiate
with terrorists, the people they perceive
to be terrorists.
If an action is correct, if an action is warranted,
you do it.
You don't let people threaten you with violence
to get you to change your actions.
But because trumpet's are likely to get violent,
if you impeach, you skip impeachment.
What Brian, what we're hearing from trumpet's
is we will respond with violence.
If Democrats use a power granted to them by
the Constitution, that's more of a confession
than a valid political statement or argument.
And what Brian Kilmeade should be saying is,
you know, it would be really stupid to go
be violent and riot in 50 states plus D.C.
again, given how terribly that went for the
country last week and given the fact that
you'd be rioting over the lies that Trump
has been telling you, which have no merit.
50 or more court cases have found that the
lies that got you to riot have no merit whatsoever.
So it's we've seen so much hypocrisy over
the last week.
And I know that hypocrisy doesn't matter to
the American right any more.
I know I've been here the last four years
as much as you have to the extent that you've
been here, if there's any three year olds
in the audience than I take it back.
We saw this with business regulation over
the last week for 40 years.
I even had a tweet that I should have I should
have pulled up here for the last 40 years.
I wrote it's been deregulate everything from
Republicans, let businesses do whatever they
want, don't enforce antitrust, get government
out of business and the people's lives.
And then all of a sudden, Republicans on January
8th regulate social media, monitor big tech,
break up monopolies, create new laws to control
business, tell businesses exactly what to
do and when they can ban someone and not ban
someone and blah, blah, blah.
And now the we will never negotiate with terrorists
crowd is saying, I don't know guys.
Aside from whether impeachment is correct,
it'll make Trump violent again.
So you shouldn't do it.
Now, Trump is the one who should have thought
of that before he incited a riot on the tail
end of two months of telling people lies that
they fell for about the election.
That's where the responsibility is, period.
And if Brian Kilmeade really wanted to do
something good for the country, he would say
to his audience, guys, whatever happens with
impeachment, whatever happens with the 25th
Amendment, don't riot.
Don't riot because you're rioting over something
that is fake.
Trump has lied to you.
You've been tricked, you've been bamboozled,
you've been deceived.
Don't go and riot.
That's not something I expect to hear Brian
Kilmeade say any time soon.
One question that's been coming up more
and more
is could or would Donald Trump pardon the
Capitol Hill rioters?